[Music]
Thunder stealer I just committed with
that one submitted by stinky tofu is
Babas PHA [ __ ] [ __ ] Bom you [ __ ]
crazy maniac you might as well take a
diary on [ __ ] tofu well I did not
hire a [ __ ] mist i wad now oh it does
smell like [ __ ] because of this think
Taiwan was amazing I love that [ __ ]
country
a wedding gets ruined when the best man
interrupts to propose to his girlfriend
during the ceremony that is crazy
I'd be [ __ ] pissed no but yeah why
would they do that it's in China it has
to be this is Chinese behavior whoa
excuse me Jill they don't have weddings
in China oh you're right I don't think
this is Chinese behavior to be honest
they don't like doing show because they
don't even they don't even propose but
don't be like get a lasso and they tie
it on the girls they can just drag them
off that's Mexican people yeah it's not
oh yeah those traditional Catholic
weddings where they take the rope over
the guy and they bring the rope over on
the girl no that's not at all what it's
for oh I thought you're talking about
three years it's as simple as I I am the
man and now I own you in the pallino
pizza oh yes stupid we'll have been
uniting it's actually a symbol of
ownership you're so sweet it is a symbol
of ownership for some reason do you know
when they died they put that's a good
one of reference for Mexican that's true
nacho libre story was the bride of this
wedding she wrote into an advice column
called dear Prudence and so we don't
know anything other than this story so I
don't know who she is where she's from
nothing I know nothing because this is
an advice column so this is what she
submitted by so the title is my
husband's best friend proposed to his
girlfriend during our wedding piece of
[ __ ] here goes my husband and I started
dating got pregnant had a child moved in
together body house and got a dog in
that order our friends and family have
asked us for years why we weren't
married
we always pushed it off to build a
better life we've done really well for
ourselves and finally reached the point
where we could afford a huge blowout
wedding to celebrate our lives with
everyone we know and love Wow my
husband's best friend John was the best
man slash officiant the setting was
beautiful everyone seemed happy our
families were overjoyed my mom may have
used the phrase hallelujah a few dozen
times the entire atmosphere felt moving
so moving in fact that John stopped mid
ceremony to propose to his longtime
girlfriend Jane and revealed her
pregnancy I couldn't even hear the vows
my husband wrote or the rest of the
ceremony over the noise of Jane's happy
sobs her very surprised family who were
also guests and people seated nearby
congratulating her that is [ __ ] up
even though the Agra fur cut cut to her
frequently during the sir
Wow can't hear anything over the chatter
they need some real ass friends that are
like do it like straight yeah I'm Telus
a like during your wedding that [ __ ] was
happening I was like hey [ __ ] you dumb
[ __ ] [ __ ] yeah my own wedding Jill
and her dad were having a moment and my
stupid-ass mom so she continues when
John gave his toast he apologized for
being caught up in the moment and then
proceeded to talk about he and Jane's
future with nary a mention of us what a
piece of [ __ ] during the reception John
and Jane became the primary focus of our
guests John
even went out of his way to ask the band
to play a special dance like him and
Jane on the dance floor I've never been
an attention hog and I wouldn't even
have minded if he'd proposed after the
ceremony but weeks later I am still
seizing I am so shocked and angry that I
kept asking myself if this is real life
I'd be [ __ ] pissed too
my husband hasn't spoken to John since
the wedding and our mutual friends think
what he did was rude but that my husband
should just get over it
my husband has joked that he'll resume
his friendship when John and Jane give
him a $40,000 check for their half of
the wedding do you think John's behavior
warrants the end of a long term
friendship or are we angry over nothing
no I think what you should do honestly
and this is coming from a man of like a
heart of forgiveness like at the end of
the day you should just stab him right
in this [ __ ] chest take a [ __ ]
knife and just go [ __ ] right there get
rid of the friend John and all your
mutual friends there just [ __ ] your
[ __ ] friends suck [ __ ] major
elephant dick - because that's come
crazy stupid or let me propose something
propose it what if the bride and groom
aren't not that fun but these two
they're really fun it's their wedding
day though I know either what if like
they're like kind of like frenemies to
all these people
but these people these two people you
really really like them so then they're
like oh yeah yeah good job and you're
like oh [ __ ] well if I had to choose
between the two I'm gonna choose this
this group right here cuz they're kind
of like you're still slimy
yeah that's pretty shitty I mean but you
people can't help feeling that way
that's why I'm saying if the whole group
enjoys these two way more I think the
ceremony is above the preference though
you guys are so honorable if I
personally like these two way more I
would have been like
yeah and they're like oh yeah it's there
still be so your shitty person cuz you
were fake I'm not fake I'm being real
yeah why would you go I don't hate them
all I'm saying is you have favorites
just like you're gonna have favorites
when you have kids you have favorite
pets whatever so it's like you don't
hate the two but it's just like you're
more happy for these two getting
together
yeah you could be happier for that
couple but there's there's a time and a
place dude because think about it why
would people be okay with this cuz
they're stupid
okay well the majority can't be stupid
I'm always thinking for why is this
happening because there's a lot of
people that are on these that are
accepting this they're so happy I'm
trying to think of somebody that I
really don't like people that are okay
with it is because they weren't the ones
getting hurt they didn't lose 80 G's so
I think the heart is gonna lie in the
original couple because they spent 80
G's on the wedding it's still laughing
so I think they're the ones that
actually got hurt and I think people are
on the sidelines they don't have any
backlash so they're not really making
they're not taking the emotions into the
consideration and first of all [ __ ] that
videographer - you're [ __ ] fired
give me my [ __ ] money back you [ __ ]
like what the hell like giving their
belt huh but this is so much more
exciting I would be pissed
that's a world star videographer hi wait
there's a thing oh hell nah they need to
have a revenge baby and announce it at
their wedding be petty as [ __ ] and then
end a friendship yep I would exactly I
would have read I would like other than
the friendship right and in the middle
of the ceremony
[ __ ] thing that like that once get at
the church runs the old guy I would just
start taking all the chairs out
[ __ ] that [ __ ] I'm causing a singing
dude I know that's pretty insane yeah do
you guys want to hear the response of
the Vice comment oh yeah so she writes I
think it merits a fight in between
getting over it and never speaking to
John again is the happy medium of having
a difficult conversation with a longtime
friend who did something selfish and
self-absorbed on your wedding day he's
your husband's best friend so your
husband should tell John just how upset
his behavior that's the first step
you should talk for sure I can't believe
they didn't even do that I meant packing
to you apologizing the two of them can
have a meaningful reconciliation and
build a better friendship as a result
there's a problem with that though there
is nothing you can say that allows me to
understand why you chose to do it at
that moment
there's no reason like you have oh my
god oh yeah yeah the only reason is that
he's selfish and all you because I could
I could see what this guy's thinking
like he's so [ __ ] oblivious and
stupid right that he's going you know
it'd be a great idea since love is in
the air yeah I'm gonna profess my love
and we're gonna share even more love
yeah so I'm gonna [ __ ] propose win
that that things going on when I'm
marrying my friends and it happens in
the [ __ ] movies okay in comedies
haven't you that comedy works like
terrible idea there's always movies
words are like yeah they're getting
married yeah and there's a proposal
happening yeah and then everyone in the
audience is probably thinking that too
oh what a coincidence there's a marriage
and another proposal love is in the air
dude I don't like be the guy like in the
crowd what am I supposed to do I gotta
back up my friend the funny thing is his
family was there and his family didn't
go what the [ __ ] are you doing I taught
you to be better than this yeah
yeah they're like oh my god this is
amazing our son or sons getting married
at a point like that does the wedding
planner can they go like reading up
right back in pretend like this never
happens that start this whole thing over
like can they do that
oh man as a wedding planner I would be
pissed you should do x out in a duel you
know time out everyone YouTube the [ __ ]
out of here
times out get the security tackle both
of them I would have done the [ __ ] it
daniel and samuel tackle out of nowhere
he was the best man the best man and the
officiant so he was marrying them and
while they were saying the vows that do
you think do you take this lovely woman
as your wife but hold up would you marry
me yeah pretty much
that's pretty fun like I would have just
said like I would have taken the mic
like yo this is inappropriately oh damn
you must have been a really nice guy and
everyone like really popular and
everyone like them
the Sienna also I also dislike the fact
that the man who is getting married is a
little [ __ ] [ __ ] ass [ __ ] Thank You
MA
yeah no it's like it's your administer
of wedding and you saw that go down you
should have you should have said some
[ __ ] maybe he was digesting it don't
rape he's like Oh cuz he's such a shock
cuz if that might Benson yeah my wedding
I'd be like what's going on is this is
this really happy I would even know what
the best ride you got true cuz when your
ma who ran up no one knew what was going
on anyway she slipped away and went back
again dude was she [ __ ] literally
like whoosh ooh jewel away my mom has
[ __ ] a black but Aikido so Bob what
are you doing she goes no funny thing is
one one push away didn't stop her she's
relentless
stick your shoulders and did a front
flip over you
hello everybody if you liked the video
make sure that you guys leave us a
thumbs up because if not I'm gonna find
you where you live and I'm gonna hug the
[ __ ] out of you with you other than that
you know there's like more videos up
there bro
[Music]